-It is time to count down the
hottest songs
at the top of the charts
right now.
Of course, here we go.
Number three,
it's "Easy On Me" by Adele.
Love that song.
Number two, we have "Heat Waves"
by Glass Animals.
And holding steady
at number one,
it's "We Don't Talk About Bruno"
by the cast
of Disney's "Encanto."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Those are the top three songs.
Now it's time to take a look
at the lowest charted songs
of this week.
This is Bottom of the Charts.
-Here we go.
-♪ Bottom of the Charts ♪
♪ Bottom of the Charts ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
So these are songs
at the bottom of the chart.
-Bottom of the chart.
-That's correct, yeah.
We just showed you the songs
at the top --
-Those are the top.
-These are the songs
at the bottom, unfortunately.
-Way down.
-On the way out of the charts.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, first up at number 97.
-Ooh.
-We have "Love Shack,
Extended Edition."
-Oh.
[ Light laughter ]
-By the B-52s.
I guess in this version,
B-52s member Fred Schneider
gives way more details
on how to --
[ Man laughs ]
How to get to the love shack.
-Really? Like more --
-Apparently this is --
the extended --
yeah, he tells you exactly --
-Where the love shack is.
-Yeah. Let's take a listen.
♪♪
-♪ Hey, if you see a faded sign
at the side of the road ♪
♪ Then you should turn at the
sign and drive into the woods ♪
♪ But the sign was pretty old
and the woods are over grown ♪
♪ So you're gonna get lost
because the sun is going down ♪
♪ Now you're arguing a lot
and it's starting to get cold ♪
♪ You hear a wolf howl ♪
♪ Wolf howl, baby ♪
-Oh, yeah. That's good, I think.
It gets scary.
Well, I hope they get there.
-Wow.
-It's exact directions.
-Yeah, that's very specific.
-Very specific.
-Well, well, well,
what do we have here?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Next up at number 98.
-Dang.
-We've got "Knife Talk"
by The Swedish Chef.
-Oh.
-Apparently, this is a cover
of the new hit Drake song,
"Knife Talk."
-Right.
-Recorded by the Swedish Chef
from The Muppets.
And he -- he knows about knives.
I mean, he's a chef.
-Yeah, he's a chef.
-Well, it comes through,
I think, in his lyrics.
I'm shocked that it's at
the bottom of the charts.
-Yeah.
-Let's take a listen to this.
♪♪
-[ Rhythmic gibberish ]
-[ Laughs ]
♪♪
-Okay. That's good, that's good,
that's good, that's good.
Look, I -- I love Swedish Chef.
-Hey.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's still charting.
-Yeah.
-Up next at number 99 is
a version
of the Backstreet Boys'
hit song,
"Show Me the Meaning
of Being Lonely."
-Oh.
-But this one's called
"Show the Meat
in that Beefaroni."
[ Laughter ]
-Really?
-I guess at some point they must
have signed an endorsement deal
with Chef Boyardee.
This song has never been
released until recently
and it broke the charts.
I mean I'm happy that
it's even charted, to be honest.
Yeah, well anyways, let's just
take a listen to this.
"Show Me the Meat
in that Beefaroni."
♪♪
-♪ Show me the meat
in that beefaroni ♪
♪ Is Chef Boyardee a real chef
or made up? ♪
♪ Tell me why it's in a can
not a jar ♪
♪ There's something zesty
in this sauce ♪
-Wow, there you go right there,
yeah.
Why is it in a can?
-Yeah.
-Not a jar.
-They're upset.
-Yeah.
-Finally, coming in
at the very bottom of the chart,
we have "We Don't Talk
About Bruno."
-Oh.
-By Vin Diesel.
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-Now, it's interesting because
it's at the top
of the charts right now.
-Right.
-And it's also, ironically,
at the bottom of the charts.
-So it's a cover of that song.
-Yeah, we all know
the original hit song.
We clapped about it earlier.
But "The Fast and the Furious"
star Vin Diesel,
our pal,
he's taken the song
and put his own signature spin
on it.
-Oh.
-Let's take a listen to it.
Here you go.
-♪ We don't talk about Bruno ♪
♪ No, no, no,
we don't talk about Bruno ♪
♪ But maybe we should ♪
♪ Because he's family ♪
♪ And the most important thing
in life is family ♪
♪ So it's time to get the gang
back together ♪
♪ Including Bruno ♪
-Oh.
-Woah!
That's what I'm talking about!
That's all from
"Bottom of the Charts."